et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier du socle bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos êtres du travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion on est
ensemble pendant plus de 20 minutes pour
un interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par Fabrice
wesser Redon du groupe Ebra bonjour
Fabrice
de cette session parlementaire repose
sur vos épaules celle des retraites
celle de l'assurance chômage on va bien
sûr en parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord un mot sur ce qui va se
passer cet après-midi à l'Assemblée
puisque trois notions de censure
déposées par l'opposition sont examinés
de la nup une du rassemblement national
est-ce que vous comprenez que les
oppositions disent qu'on ne retenant
presque aucun de leurs amendements le
gouvernement l'exécutif a bafoué la
volonté populaire exprimait leur des
législatives je pense que c'est assez
n'importe quoi pour dire mon sentiment
et je pense surtout que si nous sommes
contraint d'avoir recours à un procédé
en tout cas un outil constitutionnel
donc démocratique qui s'appelle le 49-3
c'est justement face à une situation de
blocage il faut avoir en tête que
pendant 10 jours les oppositions n'ont
eu qu'une logique s'allier
contre tout et son contraire pour battre
le gouvernement avec des résultats
absolument absurdes parfois des
amendements adoptés pour supprimer des
crédits dans la foulée des amendements
adoptés pour augmenter les mêmes crédits
et une seule volonté battre le
gouvernement c'est même aller jusqu'à
supprimer un article qui se contentait
dans le cadre de la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale de faire le point
sur l'exécution de l'année 2021 donc
c'est la démonstration qui n'avait pas
de possibilités d'une certaine manière
je peux aussi le comprendre le
comprendre parce qu'on est sur des lois
de finances que ce soit la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou la
loi de finance donc le budget de l'État
dès lors qu'on vote pour ce texte on
signe son appartenance à la majorité et
voter contre les signer son appartenance
à l'opposition donc le débat a eu lieu
il a été extrêmement vif en commission
et cela a permis à se rendre d'avancer
et à la fin il est un peu plus de 100
amendements qui sont retenus par le
gouvernement dans le cadre du texte sur
lequel nous engageons des oppositions
7% lorsque vous regardez sur les 10 15
dernières années les débats budgétaires
qui ont eu lieu 149,3 la part des
amendements de l'opposition dans les
amendements côté sur un budget c'est
rarement plus de 10%
parlez de la réforme des retraites
est-ce que un 49.3 est évitable pour
vous sur la réforme
des convergences des consensus d'abord
dans une période de dialogue social qui
va nous amener jusqu'à Noël et ensuite
dans une période de débat parlementaire
entrer dans une discussion en disant de
toute façon on terminera par un 49-3 n'a
pas de sens n'est pas intéressant je
pensais qu'il peut en être autrement je
ferai tout pour avec qui vous pourriez
avec tout le monde avec la nuque avec le
rassemblement national sur ce texte ça
m'étonnerait pas d'abord je ne veux pas
et Marine Le Pen nous a dit qu'elle ne
voulait absolument pas soutenir cette
réforme lorsque nous l'avons reçu comme
tous les présidents de groupe avec la
première ministre pour le reste je suis
ouvert à toutes les propositions y
compris la nuque y compris
vous aimeriez l'éviter j'aimerais bien
sûr comme tout le monde pour une raison
précise c'est que le sujet est très
clivant y compris dans l'opinion c'est
un sujet la réforme des retraites qui a
toujours suscité beaucoup d'inquiétude
des inquiétudes pour les personnes parce
que tout le monde se demande qui va être
concerné qui ne le sera pas de combien
tout le monde sait aussi que cette
perspective d'augmentation progressive
de l'âge de départ à la retraite elle
est assez inéluctable et en réalité
quand on regarde ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui indépendamment de l'âge
légal d'ouverture des droits de l'âge
d'autorisation
l'âge réel la geffectif de la retraite
est déjà super supérieure donc tout le
monde sait que c'est assez inéluctable
tout le monde sait aussi où en tout cas
tous ceux qui regardent voient que
autour de nous les pays européens qui
ont des économies comparables qu'il soit
dirigés par des libéraux par des
sociaux-démocrates ont tous fixé un
horizon entre 65 et 67 ans plus 167 que
65 il n'y a pas beaucoup de raisons pas
beaucoup d'explications qui amènerait un
pays comme la France à ne pas être tout
à fait la France insoumise ils veulent
revenir à la retraite à 60 ans d'euros
par an voilà vous dites c'est réaliste
c'est irréaliste c'est on sent que c'est
une épreuve pour votre gouvernement
c'est une épreuve pour tous les
gouvernements qui ont réformé les
retraites là maintenant tous les
gouvernements
parce que dans le quinquennat précédent
il y a pas eu de réforme des retraites
il y a eu un recul est-ce que là vous
irez jusqu'au
que la loi avait adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture et
qu'ensuite les débats ont été arrêtés
avec le déclenchement du covid donc il
faut pas confondre toutes les toutes les
causes oui nous irons au bout parce que
nous n'avons pas le choix nous n'avons
pas le choix d'abord c'est un engagement
il y a un besoin de justice un besoin
d'amélioration du système les pensions
sont trop basse pour des carrières
complètes la précarité n'est pas
suffisamment prise en compte la
pénibilité n'est pas suffisamment
intégrée ça c'est la première chose et
nous avons un système qui est
déséquilibré même dans les hypothèses
les plus favorables et et le rapport du
corps je rappelle toujours que le corps
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
est un organisme indépendant mais dans
son hypothèse la plus favorable
c'est-à-dire une productivité qui croit
de 1% par an un taux de chômage à 5%
2027 et durablement à 5% jusqu'en 2040
même dans ces hypothèses là c'est 12,5
milliards d'euros de déficit en 2027 et
presque 15 milliards par an en 2030 donc
il y a une nécessité d'agir c'est ce que
nous allons faire mais faire cette
réforme ne signifie pas foncez bien en
tête c'est chercher les convergences
chercher les condenses en Suisse c'est
le sens du social et des concertations
qui ont ouvertes est-ce que vous nous
confirmez que ça sera le premier texte
examiné en Conseil des ministres à la
rentrée du mois de janvier je vous
confirme que ce sera un texte examiné au
mois de janvier pas forcément le premier
c'était pas moi qui décide de l'ordre du
jour du conseil des ministres
et l'isolation avec le Parlement donc il
est mieux informé que moi sur le
l'action de calendrier mais en tout cas
pour être tout à fait clair nous avons
un calendrier qui a été fixé par le
président de la République qui est que
nous ferons le bilan des concertations
avant Noël nous dirons quelle est la
réforme avant Noël et nous inscrirons
cette réforme au parlementaire
sur les compromis possibles est-ce que
vous discutez encore avec tous les
syndicats c'est à dire y compris avec la
CGT la CGT nous a indiqué il y a une
petite quinzaine de jours que elle était
extrêmement hostile au réquisition dans
les raffineries de pétrole dans le cadre
du conflit social des raffineries et que
parce que notre gouvernement a procédé
et je considère que c'est très normal à
des réquisitions elle suspendait sa
participation non pas à la seule
discussion sur les retraites mais à
toute forme de dialogue social tant avec
le gouvernement qu'avec les
représentants des employeurs la CGT nous
a aussi dit qu'elle ne viendrait pas
donc au bilatéral sur l'usure la
pénibilité l'emploi des seniors mais
qu'elle ferait une contribution par
écrit nous regarderons ce qui est
distribution classique
sur le vous les appelez à revenir à la
tablette la porte est ouverte et je l'ai
dit je le répète à tous les partenaires
sociaux m'apporte est toujours ouverte
sur le calendrier puisqu'il va vous
chercher un compromis vous dites on va
essayer de pas faire 39-3 ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir trouver un compromis
vous partez pour le moment sur un report
de l'âge légal de départ de quatre mois
par an pour aboutir à 65 ans en 2031
est-ce que ça vous pourriez revenir sur
ce calendrier est-ce que ça fait partie
des compromis possibles c'est le mandat
sur lequel le président de la République
s'est engagé devant les Français donc
non c'est ce mandat qui nous sert de
piste de de lignes directrices à
l'ouverture des discussions mais cela a
été dit par le Président de la
République et par la première ministre
il n'y a pas de totem il n'y a pas de
tabou nous avons deux priorités absolues
de de lignes rouges si je puis dire en
tout cas de ligne directrice la première
c'est d'améliorer le système j'ai évoqué
le niveau des pensions j'ai évoqué la
pénibilité et la prise en compte des
carrières hachées donc de la précarité
il y a une deuxième ligne rouge qui est
l'équilibre du système parce que
améliorer le système sans équilibrer ça
n'est pas responsable et se contenter de
l'équilibrer sans l'améliorer ça ne
serait pas juste et donc nous avons ces
deux lignes rouges et nous verrons d'ici
la fin de la période de concertation
avant Noël comment nous pouvons
articuler ces deux limites dans le cadre
c'est pas forcément une ligne rouge ça
n'est pas un totem ça n'est pas un tabou
mais c'est ce sur quoi le président de
la République s'est engagé ce sur quoi
nous sommes légitime c'est donc le cadre
de notre discussion sur Nicolas Sarkozy
vous l'avez sans doute lu hier à Nicolas
Sarkozy dans le Journal du dimanche il
dit qu'il vaut mieux passer à 63 ans
tout de suite plutôt qu'à 65 ans dans 10
ans ce qui est votre réforme vous
souscrivez à ce qu'il se dit j'ai lu
avec intérêt l'interview de Nicolas
Sarkozy d'abord elle était longue elle
apporte de nombreux sujets et puis
Nicolas
et je respecte tous les anciens
présidents de la République pour les
fonctions qu'ils ont exercé Nicolas vous
soutient enfin il soutient Emmanuel
Macron sur la réforme de en fait en tout
cas j'ai lu ce qu'il avait dit sur la
réforme des retraites
un peu différente qui consiste à
augmenter l'âge de départ de ma raison
de 3 ou 4 mois par an pendant une
période progressive je pense que pour
toute réforme de cette nature la
progressivité est plutôt bonne
conseillère mais voilà c'est une
contribution au débat il y en a eu
d'autres sur le rythme sur la méthode
mais sur les compromis en fait quel
compromis vous êtes prêts à faire et
avec les parlementaires et avec les
syndicats puisque Laurent Berger qui est
plutôt le syndicat avec lequel vous avez
le plus de facilité à travailler il dit
les 65 ans c'est net c'est pas parce
qu'il y a des facilités qui n'est pas
l'exigence de leur part et c'est très
bien comme ça je considère que le rôle
des organisations syndicales d'abord
leur appartient mais quand il est
exigence il y a aussi possibilité de
discussions et possibilité de challenger
un peu pardon pour le mauvais français
il y a tout un champ de sujets de thème
sur lesquels nous pouvons avancer la
question de la prise en compte de la
pénibilité donc la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle la question de la
formation la question de la gestion de
la fin de carrière et donc des
conditions des seniors les questions
relatives à la santé au travail moi je
lui ai dit aux organisations syndicales
et aux organisations patronales ce n'est
pas parce que nous aurons un point
d'accord sur tel ou tel sujet que je
considèrerais que j'affirmerai qu'ils
sont d'accord sur tout et donc j'accepte
très volontiers que nous puissions avoir
un désaccord par exemple avec les
organisations syndicales sur des
questions d'âge ou durée de cotisation
mais que ça ne nous empêche pas de
trouver des points de convergence sur
d'autres sujets d'accord
il y aura forcément recul de l'âge de
départ ça c'est pas négociable comment
pardon mais est-ce que ce sera 65 ans
c'est ça
que notre système est structurellement
et durablement déséquilibré la première
la première engagement la première
responsabilité c'est de faire en sorte
que les générations qui viennent
puissent aussi bénéficier de ce système
par répartition ça c'est la première
chose donc nous travaillons dans ce sens
il n'y a pas d'autres possibilités que
de travailler plus pour y arriver
travailler plus c'est travailler plus
collectivement c'est ce que nous faisons
pour Le Pen emploi c'est aussi
travailler plus à l'échelle d'une
carrière maintenant compte de ceux qui
ont commencé très tôt en tenant compte
de la prévention de l'usure ça n'est pas
une logique totalement uniforme pour
tout le monde vous l'avez cité deux fois
la prévention de l'usure c'est une vraie
question cet emploi des seniors on va
vers un allongement des carrières vous
venez de le dire de le répéter sans
réforme c'est le cas même sans réforme
c'est le cas et en même temps on voit
bien que beaucoup de seniors ont du mal
à retrouver un emploi ou simplement
garder le leur il y a quand même un
paradoxe à faire travailler les gens
plus longtemps et aujourd'hui avoir des
difficultés à leur trouver ou la
conserver un emploi d'abord il y a un
certain nombre de choses qu'il faut
avoir en tête parce qu'ils sont parfois
un peu contre-intuitives
le risque de perdre d'emploi des seniors
et globalement moins élevé que les
autres générations par contre ce que
l'on voit c'est qu'il y a effectivement
parfois dans tel ou telle entreprise
donc de tentation où j'allais dire
facilité mais le terme est un propre de
se séparer d'abord des seniors lorsqu'on
doit se séparer de personnel dans le
cadre économique des raisons économiques
le fait par exemple que les systèmes de
protection d'assurance chômage sont plus
protecteur pour plus de 53 ans pour les
plus de 55 ans avec des durées maximum
d'Inde d'indemnisation qui peuvent
varier
pas du simple double mais de 1 et demi
ça c'est une première chose il y a une
deuxième chose c'est qu'on voit aussi
que l'accès à la formation tant en
termes d'investissement des entreprises
sur les plans de formation que d'accès
individuels à la formation et moitié
moins important pour les plus de 50 ans
que pour les moins de 50 ans dans les
entreprises il y a un certain nombre
d'exemples de pays européens je pense
notamment à la Suède mais pas seulement
ou il y a des efforts qui sont fermes
matières d'accès à la formation des
seniors il y a des entreprises en France
qui mettent en place des plans de
formation pour les salariés de plus de
50 ans pour leur permettre aussi
d'envisager une fin de carrière
différente je pense que c'est une des
clés que permettre de garantir l'accès à
la formation pour les plus de 50 ans
c'est aussi ce qui permet d'avoir accès
à d'autres postes que celui qu'on occupe
et en particulier quand on occupe des
postes avec un risque d'usure
professionnelle avec un risque de
pénibilité mais il faut regarder cela
les organisations d'employeur nous
disent qu'une des clés pourrait être de
nouvelles exonérations en matière de
cotisation patronales les organisations
syndicales nous disent qu'il faudrait
peut-être réfléchir à un index pour
mesurer des entreprises en matière
d'emploi des seniors regardons-le mais
l'index vous le regardez encore c'est
une sorte de quota finalement quotas du
nombre de seigneurs le Medef veut pas
est-ce que du coup vous allez renoncer à
ce point le seul partenaire social vous
renoncez pas la même manière que la CFDT
n'est pas le seul et nous devons
regarder chacune des pistes par contre
et la concertation est encore en cours
donc je ne vais pas préjugé de l'issue
de cette concertation il faut que l'on
permette le retour à l'emploi des
seniors il faut surtout que l'on
permettre le maintien dans l'emploi des
seigneurs pourquoi est-ce que je dis
cela c'est parce que le chiffre pardon
j'en donne beaucoup mais un des chiffres
qui montrent l'intérêt de maintenir les
seigneurs dans l'emploi c'est que
lorsque vous avez plus de 50 ans et que
vous perdez votre emploi vous mettez en
moyenne deux fois plus de temps pour en
retrouver un que lorsque vous avez moins
de 50 ans et donc ça montre combien le
maintien dans l'emploi est primordial et
son maintien dans l'emploi dont tout
faire pour qu'il soit possible à la fois
par la prévention par la santé au
travail et par la formation un dernier
mot là-dessus la suppression des régimes
spéciaux vous irez jusqu'au bout c'est
aussi l'engagement du président de la
République et c'est une question donc ça
ça sera tenu sur la réforme de
l'assurance sur ma chaîne l'autre
réforme que vous portez le scénar
l'examine à partir de demain elle a déjà
été votée par l'Assemblée nationale ça
module les allocations en fonction de la
conjoncture
au gouvernement de décider des règles
d'indemnisation jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 par décret et nous avons annoncé
que dans le cadre de ce décret nous
étions une modulation des règles
d'indemnisation mais pas du montant des
allocations c'est une ligne rouge que
j'ai tracé donc touchons pas au montant
des allocations et on va venir sur durée
mais pas de montant on va venir sur ce
détail dans quelques instants mais le
texte a été durci par les sénateurs en
commission est-ce que du coup vous
pensez un compromis possible sur ce
texte en position là ils vont le débat
va débuter demain en séance au Sénat
avec les sénateurs avec notamment le
rapporteur Frédéric cuissard j'ai vu les
amendements adopter en commission
certains vont dans le bon sens ça
apporte des précisions je pense
notamment à la question du CDD
multi-remplacement qui est une facilité
protectrice à la fois des employeurs et
des employés dans le cadre de
remplacement notamment pendant les
périodes de bouger dans les secteurs
comme la distribution ça permet de faire
des contrats plus longs et ça évite au
chef d'entreprise d'avoir un contrat par
salarié remplacé le temps d'une période
de congés donc il y a des choses qui
sont intéressantes je trouve intéressant
qu'ils aient introduit et renforcer la
base légale permettant ce qu'on appelle
la contracyclicité il y a des choses que
le Sénat aussi adopté en commission
notamment pour réduire de manière assez
forte les dispositions relatives au
bonus malus et je trouve que la
réduction est trop importante et fait
perdre de son sens ils ont allégé les
pénalités plus les entreprises pour vous
c'est pas bon et ils ont réduit le champ
d'application des dispositions de la
réforme de 2019 et c'est un des points
avec lesquels nous ne partageons pas la
position de la Commission des affaires
sociales mais il y a un débat il y aura
un débat au cours duquel j'aurai
l'occasion de faire valoir les positions
du gouvernement il y aura une commission
mixte paritaire à laquelle le
gouvernement participe pas il faut le
rappeler mais
principe je considère que sur tout texte
la recherche du compromis est une bonne
chose bon alors justement on va rentrer
dans le détail puisque vous parlez de
ces critères de modulation vous l'avez
dit vous nous le redis vous ne toucherez
pas au montant des indemnités mais quidd
des conditions d'entrée dans ce régime
puisque c'est sur ça et quelle sera la
durée d'indemnisation des éléments de
concertation à la fois les conditions
d'entrée la réforme de 2019 avait déjà
modifié ceci auparavant il fallait
justifier de 4 mois de cotisation sur
les 28 derniers mois désormais c'est six
mois sur 24 faut qu'on puisse le
regarder souhaitez-vous pour aujourd'hui
le gouvernement a ouvert cette piste à
la concertation j'ai indiqué par
ailleurs que la période de six mois me
paraissait une bonne période d'abord
parce que donc on touche pas beaucoup de
ce on va laisser la constatation se
dérouler et voir ce que propose les
partenaires sociaux elle est en cours
mais beaucoup de ceux qui rentrent dans
le marché du travail peuvent entrer par
un CDD et ou globalement il est souvent
des CDD de six mois que des CDD de 7
donc il faut aussi tenir compte de ce
qui existe sur le marché du travail et
faire preuve de pragmatisme et sur la
durée la question de la durée maximale
mais je pense que celle-ci peut être
moduler il faut trouver les bons
indicateurs pour cela qu'est-ce que ça
signifie une bonne situation du marché
de l'emploi et je considère
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
bonne situation il y a évidemment des
des inquiétudes macroéconomiques liées à
l'énergie à l'inflation mais globalement
situation aujourd'hui ça serait combien
la durée d'indemnisation pour vous je ne
souhaite pas qu'on entre uniquement par
des questions de taux de chômage ou de
taux de croissance il faut plutôt
regarder le nombre d'emplois disponibles
par rapport au nombre de demandeurs
inscrits regardez les difficultés de
recrutement et s'appuyer aussi sur les
indicateurs du BIT je réponds
international du tract il y a une
concertation qui est en cours et nous
avons ouvert ses champs à la fois les
conditions d'affiliation et la durée
d'indemnisation et la concertation mais
vous pensez qu'elle peut aboutir cette
conscience entre les partenaires
sociaux
tous je préfère la concertation et nous
sommes dans la période de concertation
je l'ai ouverte la semaine dernière les
partenaires sociaux plusieurs semaines
de discussion ambilatérale avec nous
pour nous faire des propositions y
compris par écrit pour échanger sur les
solutions techniques et donc nous
verrons comment nous sortons de tout
cela dans quelques semaines sur un
accord
dans la mesure ça n'est pas une
négociation n'est pas la recherche d'un
accord majoritaire mais évidemment des
techniques il faut bien que la
concertation aboutisse sinon ça veut
dire que c'est le gouvernement qui
reprend la main pardon mais dans le cas
d'une concertation telle que le Conseil
d'État nous a suggéré de la monnaie
c'est-à-dire en application du Préambule
de la Constitution de 46 sur la
participation des organisations
représentatives des salariés aux
conditions de travail il n'y a pas de
recherche de négociation d'accord qui
serait majoritaire il n'y a pas de
dilapasser pardon pour cette ville
formule il y a simplement une
consultation un échange et notre
objectif évidemment d'enrichir nos
positions un dernier mot là-dessus après
je laisse la main Fabrice les sénateurs
ils vous demandent de renoncer à une
lettre de cadrage pour cette
concertation et de plutôt faire une
lettre d'orientation c'est-à-dire de
laisser plus de place au paritarisme
est-ce que là dessus vous allez dire
confusion entre deux sujets il y a un
sujet sur les questions d'indemnisation
est-ce que souhaitent les sénateurs en
matière de nature de de discussion
concerne la gouvernance de l'assurance
chômage c'est un sujet différent je me
suis engagé auprès des partenaires
sociaux parce que dans la foulée de la
concertation sur les règles d'in nous
puissions offrir une négociation c'est à
dire la recherche d'un accord national
interprofessionnel avec des règles de
majorité sur les questions de
gouvernance et j'ai d'ores j'ai d'ores
et déjà dit qu'indépendamment du choix
entre l'aide de cadrage document
d'orientation mais c'est pas rien c'est
ce que vous reproche les sénateurs les
sénateurs ils vous disent c'est trop
cadrés par le gouvernement il faut
laisser plus de place au parité je
souhaite que cette ouverture de
négociation sur la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage au premier semestre
2023 c'est une ouverture une ouverture
négociation dans un cadre très ouvert et
je ne fermerai aucune des pistes il y a
une piste que le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas avoir mise en oeuvre qui
est celle de l'étatisation de
l'assurance chômage mais nous savons que
sur la base d'un certain nombre de
rapport y compris des rapports
parlementaires il y a quatre grandes
familles dont une quiétatisation nous ne
souhaitons pas tout sera ouvert une
question toute simple quel est
l'objectif est-ce que c'est d'en finir
avec les abus
c'est à dire des gens qui abuseraient de
l'assurance sur la fin franchement la
plupart des lance majorité des
demandeurs d'emploi que je connais et
que je rencontre que nous connaissons
sont à la recherche d'un emploi on
trouvera toujours des situations d'abus
qu'on est des règles plus incitatives
collectivement plus incitatives oui ne
comptez pas sur moi pour entrer dans une
stigmatisation de tel ou telle demandeur
d'emploi ni de faire de cas particuliers
même si je sais que cas particulier
s'accorde au pluriel dans ce cas là pour
définir une règle ou pire jeter le
propre sur ceux qui sont à la recherche
d'un emploi Fabrice
vous êtes confronté à une situation un
changement assez spectaculaire du
rapport des Français au travail ça vous
l'aviez pas prévu vous l'aviez pas
anticipé je suis pas sûr que quiconque
est prévu je pense que c'est un
changement qui est assez structurel et
que la période de covid avec le
développement extrêmement rapide et
parfois même un peu improvisé mais cela
a marché quand même du télétravail les
interrogations aussi que le cette
période de confinement de distance avec
le travail on peut faire sur Internet
sont autant d'éléments qui accélèrent
cette ça vous complique les choses quand
même ça vous complique non c'est
intéressant et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'à la suite du Conseil national de la
refondation le président de la
République a souhaité qu'on ouvre parmi
les travaux thématiques un conseil
national thématique qu'on appelle les
assises du travail pour justement avoir
une réflexion collective sur le sens du
travail sur la relation du travail c'est
la place qu'on lui donne à l'échelle de
nos vies à l'échelle de la société donc
vous lancez un nouveau plan là
pour arriver à pourvoir des milliers
d'emplois que vous n'arrivez pas pour
moi mais les assises du travail c'est
une réflexion collective que nous aurons
mais oui actuellement à indépendamment
de ces assises et pour faire face aux
difficultés de recrutement j'ai demandé
à Pôle emploi de lancer la phase 2 du
plan de réduction des tensions ce n'est
pas la même chose je continue pardon sur
j'essaie de finir sur les assises du
travail et le débat de société sur le
sens du travail
je pense que il y a une recherche de
sens je pense que nous devons nous
réinterroger sur la place du travail
dans nos vies c'est un débat qui est
intéressant je pense aussi qu'il faut se
tenir écarter de faux sujets on nous
parle tout le temps de la grande
démission parce que au premier semestre
2022 il y aurait eu plus de 500000
d'émissions c'est un fait établi mais
l'essentiel l'immense majorité de cette
émission sont des démissions dans le cas
de mobilité pour aller vers de nouveaux
emplois la grande démission comme on
peut la voir ou l'entrevoir aux
États-Unis qui consiste à avoir sortir
des dizaines de milliers de personnes du
travail de l'activité économique ce
n'est pas ce que nous connaissons nous
avons un taux d'emploi qui bat des
records depuis 1971 être à un moment de
notre histoire ou on n'a jamais eu
autant proportionnellement en proportion
de Français qui travaillent ce n'est pas
une grande démission un mot sur France
travail qui est qui va remplacer Pôle
Emploi le chantier là est en cours
combien de départements ont candidaté
pour être départemental expérimentaux il
y a deux sujets il y a à la fois le
chantier France travaille consiste à
mieux coordonner les acteurs du travail
avoir une meilleure capacité à
accueillir les demandeurs d'emploi poser
un diagnostic sur leurs compétences
leurs besoins de compétences et de
qualifications à mieux accueillir
l'échelle d'entreprise qui recrutent
c'est le sens de la mission de
préfiguration qui est qui est en cours
et nous avons intégré dans cette mission
l'engagement du président de la
République de mieux accompagner les
bénéficiaires du RSA pour faciliter le
retour à l'emploi aujourd'hui quand on
regarde les bénéficiaires du RSA
l'immense majorité bénéficie d'un
accompagnement social mais selon sur
deux un peu moins d'un sur deux
bénéficie d'un accompagnement pour un
projet professionnel moi ma conviction
c'est que la société ne sera quitte de
son devoir de solidarité que lorsque
elle aura permis le retour à l'emploi la
location ça ne suffit pas ça se
contentait de verser la location n'est
pas satisfaisant il faut qu'il y ait des
activités d'insertion de formation ça
n'est pas du bénévole bénévolat
bénévolat obligatoire comme j'ai pu
l'entendre ça n'est pas du travail
obligatoire ou gratuit ce qui n'existe
pas dans mon esprit c'est vraiment de
l'insertion et de la formation nous
avons la trentaine de départements
candidates auront vocation à être
départements expérimentaux non vous
allez en choisir parmi la trentaine une
grosse dizaine parce que mener une
expérimentation c'est utile mais il faut
pouvoir mener cette expérimentation sur
un nombre de territoires suffisamment
important pour bien couvrir les
différentes situations mais pas trop
pour que l'expérimentation soit
particulièrement bien suivie nous allons
choisir ces départements un dernier mot
au chef de territoire de progrès c'est
l'aile gauche de la majorité est-ce que
quelle est l'avenir de territoire de
progrès est-ce que vous allez vous
fondre dans Renaissance est-ce que vous
avez vocation à rejoindre horizon
horizon c'est quand même une formation
qui est à la droite de la majorité donc
ça va être un progrès est à la gauche de
la majorité j'ai lu ce fantasme ici ou
là peut-être que ça s'explique la
question des liens d'amitié assez fort
et très fort que j'ai avec Édouard
Philippe donc non mais je ne vois pas
trop la cohérence d'un tel rapprochement
par contre pour ce qui concerne
territoire de progrès nous sommes nous
avons vocation à être un parti associé
de renaissance avec un certain nombre de
de dirigeants de cadre de territoire
progrès nous participons à la fois à la
gouvernance et à la fondation de cette
nouvelle organisation de la majorité
pour plus d'unité et avec cette volonté
de faire vivre des idées progress
social-démocrate dans la majorité
présidentielle mais vous restez un parti
membre de renaissance ou vos allocations
vous fondre dans votre naissance c'est
le point le plus important et le congrès
de territoire progrès qui aura lieu dans
quelques semaines actera tout cela ce
sera la décision des militants vous avez
lu Nicolas Sarkozy vous nous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il habite Emmanuel Macron
a regardé un peu plus à droite ça vous
pose problème s'il avait toute l'amitié
que vous avez ici c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
avait invité Emmanuel Macron a regardé
plus à gauche j'aurais été surpris il
est dans son rôle il est dans son
positionnement et je me dis j'ai lu son
interview avec
l'intérêt avec un certain soutien aussi
à Monsieur Darmanin mais Gérald que
Nicolas Sarkozy souvienne générale
ça me fait plaisir pour Gérald parce que
c'est aussi un ami merci vous avez
beaucoup d'amis
mais c'est la preuve qu'on peut aussi
faire de la politique
des liens d'amitié parce que vous n'avez
pas interrogé sur ce que j'ai à gauche
sans nom
merci beaucoup
merci Fabrice on passe au club des
territoires
[Musique]